So this morning I'm talking to
Sally Okun who's the Vice President
of Advocacy, Policy, and Public Safety
at Patients Like Me here in Cambridge.
Sally, thank you so much for
taking the time to be with us today.
>> Thank you for having me Mark.
I really appreciate
the chance to talk to you.
>> So we've talked before,
and I'm always fascinated by the story
of how Patients Like Me came to be.
So, would you tell us that story?
>> Sure, absolutely.
You know, it's not uncommon at all for
a one patient or
a one family story to actually
be a driver behind innovation.
Whether it's in healthcare or
some other experience.
And for our company,
it was very much that.
So, Stephen Haywood, who was 29 at
the time he was diagnosed with ALS,
had two brothers, Jamie and Ben Haywood.
And a good friend Jeff Cole,
who at the time of Steven's diagnosis
decided to dive in deeply and
figure out how they might help to
stall the progression of his disease.
Or, in fact, try to cure his disease.
All of them coming out of MIT,
engineer-minded and
solution oriented, and so
they really wanted to find some ways of
being able to help Stephen through this.
What they found was rather frustrating.
A lot of the research wasn't
available for them to be able get at.
Some of the information that they
were receiving was conflicting.
And they ultimately decided that much
of what they were actually learning was
from other patients and families who
were dealing with the same issues.
And decided that they really needed to
find a way of being able to bring those
patients and families together to better
learn and connect with each other.
And ultimately find ways of being able
to monitor track their own experiences.
Bringing that together, you start to
learn about the collective experience
and the collective
wisdom of everyone else.
So Patients Like Me was actually
born out of that kind of model.
Bringing people together, helping them
find different ways of being able
to problem solve in their own times of
living with illness, but also finding
ways of being able to connect to the
opportunities to contribute to research.
And that was a big
component of what we do.
>> Well, there's a wonderful story about
the ALS community on patients like me,
contributing to research around
a report out of Italy I think it was,
that maybe lithium would
benefit these patients.
Can you tell us about that?
>> Sure.
You're exactly right.
It was a small Italian study that
was done and it indicated, or
it claimed actually that the use of
lithium carbonate was actually slowing
the progression of ALS in
a small subset of patients.
What our patients on the site, who
are already part of a community that was
tracking and monitoring their condition,
many of them went to their doctors and
said I want to try Lithium.
And in this particular population,
the doctors will oftentimes try to work
with their patients to try to determine
an appropriate use for
an off label indication.
So in this case many of
the patients started using Lithium.
In fact,
we had about 348 patients on the site,
who were actively taking Lithium
under their clinician's review and
starting to track their
experience with that.
And they came to us, very activated,
to say can you help us start to gather
the data in such a way that we can
actually start to determine whether or
not this claim from this
study is right or wrong.
What we learned in a very short
period of time, quite frankly,
in nine months, we were able to
demonstrate with this group of patients,
that the claims that were made in
the initial study were not holding up,
that the progression was continuing.
There was no indication that the
progression was slowing as a result of
using the product.
So we took that opportunity to suggest
that this was an environment within
which patients who are activated and
interested in participating in research
could contribute their data
in a very meaningful way.
We took it to the next step, however.
Because we understood that
we have a biased population.
So our research scientists and data
scientists spent time developing a novel
algorithm where they could match
patients who were using Lithium
with patients who actually had a similar
disease course but were not on Lithium.
So they were able to create a control
group, that actually then was
useful in being able to support the
report that we ultimately showed, which
was that Lithium really did not have
an impact on the progression of ALS.
In fact you know, for
some patient's it could have been
a concern because they were actually
taking a drug that might have had
adverse effects that they didn't
necessarily need to incur.
It was a great opportunity to show the
power of the patient research network.
>> So, you began with amyotrophic
lateral sclerosis but
you've certainly expanded
well beyond that.
Can you tell us about the other
conditions or the number of
conditions and the number of communities
are now on Patients Like Me.
>> Sure.
We currently have about
270,000 patients on the site.
We cover over 2,000
different conditions.
Initially when we came out of the first
few years with Patients Like Me,
we were really relatively
small communities that were
focusing a lot on these very serious,
neurological conditions similar to ALS.
With MS and that sort of thing.
And since then we've really
expanded quite a bit.
So today we have communities
are focused on, Multiple Sclerosis is
one of our largest communities still,
about 40,000 patients.
We have a very large community
of fibromyalgia patients.
Patients for whom the system
isn't necessarily very helpful.
Because it's such as complex
condition with a lot of symptoms, and
not a treatment in sight right now.
Many mood conditions.
So we have a lot of patients
who are using the site for
monitoring their depression or
their anxiety disorders.
But then other conditions such as
epilepsy, rheumatoid arthritis,
many of those are also in
the thousands of patients.
We're seeing more and more,
some of the more rare conditions and
often times, parents coming on to
the sites to start to monitor and
track their children who have some
unusual and rare conditions as well.
So, it's really expanded,
just, exponentially, frankly,
from where we began and it's very
exciting to have the opportunity to
have so
many different conditions represented.
>> Well this is a health
informatics course, and
I know from discussions we've had
in the past that there is a lot of
informatics sitting under this beautiful
user friendly, non technical site.
Can you tell us a bit about what it
takes to actually make this thing work?
>> Sure it does take
a lot of engineering.
Much of our company,
we have about 80 staff now.
Much of our company are engineers,
software developers,
designers, user experience specialists.
Then we also have the other side of
the house which is research scientists,
data scientist and clinicians, who are
trying to bring the two worlds together,
very much in health IT perspective.
So on the clinical side, for example, we
actually take all of the data that comes
in from patients, and we actually
code that against the standardized
terminologies that you would find in
an electronic health record for example.
>> Can you tell us which ones?
>> Sure, we actually code against most
of the ones that you would imagine.
So ICD, SNOMED, we use mEDRA for
side effect data,
which is what the pharmaceutical
industry as well as the FDA uses for
monitoring adverse events.
We use Multum database right now for
our drug database.
But we're moving more
towards using RxNorm.
Again another one of the standardized
terminologies that's within
the UMLS library.
So we try very much to
use existing standardized
databases in order to be able to
normalize our data in some way.
So that it ultimately could be able to
be interoperable with other systems.
Right now that's not as transparent
on the site as you might imagine, but
when you go behind the scenes,
we can then begin to look at
how many ways have people
talked about their symptom,
against a particular
specific clinical concept.
And there could be 30 different
ways that patients actually express
one clinical concept.
So, that's actually contributing to
the development of a patient vocabulary
that actually maps back
to clinical concepts.
And there's probably close to eight or
9,000 terms in there now that are in
patient's voice that we've actually
then mapped to clinical concepts.
>> Super.
I know you've recently, we talked
earlier about clinical research, and
you emphasized that the Lithium study
really isn't a controlled trial,
in the classic sense.
But you guys are helping your users,
your patients find and get involved
in clinical trials, I understand.
Can you tell us about that?
>> I can.
And we have a few ways of doing that.
One is that we download every night,
the data from cliinicaltrials.gov.
And so a patient can look at their
profile the next morning and see,
based on their profile data, which
trials they actually matched against,
within 25 miles of their home.
Gives them a place to begin.
Then we've also just recently
announced a service that we're
going to be provided to
the pharmaceutical industry.
It's called Trial Access.
We've learned from our patients through
surveys that we've done with them,
that many of them have been invited
to participate in trials, and
many of them have not been
satisfied with the experience of
those who actually did participate.
Sometimes it's because there wasn't
enough patient-oriented consideration
into what it took to
participate in a trial.
So what we've learned is that by having
this service called Trial Access,
we're actually going to be
helping patients participate
in the development of trials,
right from the very start.
So they're better able to say, this
particular intervention is going to be
very inconvenient for
me to be able to do.
Had you considered that?
Now another way of being able
to state that could be, if
I'm going to have to have a blood sample
drawn, we need to determine how far away
I'm going to need to go to get that, or
can someone come to my home and do that?
So there's different ways that patients
can actually contribute practical advice
to the child development [CROSS_TALK].
>> So patient-centered clinical trials.
>> Absolutely.
>> A new concept.
>> All the way through the system.
And actually even also to the point
where they are participating in
the evaluation of that trial.
How did it go?
And being able to get some
findings back to them.
Right now,
you participate in a clinical trial and
you never know what the outcomes
of that trial were.
And if you have access to a journal, you
might be able to find the publication at
some point, but
much of that data isn't published.
What we're saying, and
we're suggesting, and
we're hoping, that the industry
really begins to embrace.
Patients need to have some feedback.
There needs to be a mechanism that
if I've contributed my data and
I'm participating in this study.
I'd like to have some sense
of how it all went and
how it did contribute to new knowledge.
>> Well great, so that sort of leads
to my last question, which is,
I'm going to ask you to
get out your crystal ball.
What do you see as the future
of Patients Like Me,
at least that you can discuss?
And specifically,
and I'm not sure I know the answer
to this one, as I'll be interested.
How do you see Patients Like Me
being involved in VDT, the move for
patients to be able to upload
their electronic records and
share their data with each other and
with other clinicians?
Well, we have a lot of
exciting things going on.
And some of the projects that
we're currently working on
are very much about that.
We're doing some testing and
piloting of sensors and
mobile devices and wearables.
Trying to figure out ways of being able
to give patients the opportunity to have
access to these devices, bringing
that data into our platform, and then
ultimately finding a way of bringing
that data into the clinical records, so
it can be useful.
But there's a lot that you, as you might
imagine, that goes along with that.
We need to think about how
do we standardize that data,
how do we understand how
to code that data so,
we're just really beginning to learn and
those projects are just launched.
We've just actually sent out the
packages to the patient participants, so
they can start to do that
active data collection.
We see the platform as being an
environment where patients can truly be
a part of the changing healthcare
system in an area where we've
never really had access to their voice
in such a systematic way before.
And we believe that, actually,
that contribution will
really help us achieve the promise of
a continuously learning health system.
Without that voice, we're sort of
operating in a bit of a vacuum.
So we are continuing to build
the platform with that in mind.
We hope, within the next year or so,
to really have the ability to have that
interoperability data exchange, so that
we might be able to pull in data from
an EHR record, to unburden the patient
from having to enter all that data in.
But you know,
there's another facet to that.
The patient can also verify the data.
>> Exactly.
>> And really reconcile
the medication list for example,
as part of the helping to then
achieve something that an electronic
health record holder needs to do.
They need to reconcile
the medication record and
this is a way of being able to do that.
So there's a variety of ways that we see
our ability to be able to take advantage
of that kind of view, download and
transmit type of technology.
But we want it to be bidirectional.
Let's get data going back and forth.
So that ultimately each record is
a reflection of the full 360 view of
the patient.
>> You raise a really interesting point.
I was at a talk recently from
someone at the Geisinger Clinic.
Which is a very well known
health system in Pennsylvania.
And they have an open chart initiative,
which allows patients to
see their actual charts.
And one of the benefits they've
seen is that patients find and
help them correct mistakes.
>> Errors, exactly.
You know, it's really very common for
something to be on a record that isn't
quite accurate, or for a patient to see
a medication that they may have taken,
ten years ago, but no longer take, and
be able to say to the doctor, this is
not accurate let's fix it together.
One of the things I've been playing
around with is this equation, and
I've been talking about it a lot lately,
and that's this notion of shared data.
So my data as a patient, your data
as a clinician, our data together.
Actually can, when you add that into
a shared decision making model,
ultimately leads to a shared
accountability for the outcomes.
So that we actually all have
the opportunity to share in
the ways that I can improve my health.
I can have my health be more
reflective of what matters to me.
But at the same time I'm understanding
the kinds of things that are,
a clinician needs to know in order
to be able to take better care of
the needs that I have so.
>> Well as soon as I
get back to Atlanta,
I'm going to encourage our
friend Marla to sign up.
So if you see a woman with a lot
of problems named Marla sign up,
you should know that I sent her to you.
>> Well the other thing to keep in mind
with that in mind is that the site has
levels of privacy that allow a patient
to use a username or their real name.
But I would want to be sure that people
do know that we do take great strides to
be sure that the experience for patients
is safe, they can trust the site,
they can feel comfortable about
being able to exchange information.
>> Students know who Marly is,
you don't.
>> I don't [LAUGH].
>> Thank you very much.
>> Oh, thank you.
>> Great talking to you.